On this episode, I answer book
questions on my book day.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and it's episode 190 of
the #AskGaryVee show.
I have a fun idea for
the editing, Staphon
make sure I don't forget.
Vayner Nation big heartfelt thank you.
Obviously, I gave you a huge
rant at the end of 189.
We don't need to go
through that again.
So if you're watching 190 right now
because we put out
189 late, you alright?
- [India] Yeah.
Since we put out 189 late
that episode ended with the
heartfelt thank you for everybody.
Today is book day, I am leaving
in a second to go to St. Louis.
I will see so many of you tonight
at a big, big book event
with my boy Andy.
Looking forward to that.
I will bring serious fire.
Actually, you know what, Staphon
we haven't edited in a while.
Fire! Make it come out of my mouth.
There we go. Feeling good.
Feeling good about the book.
Last night, CNN was good.
Talked a little Snapchat and politics.
India got a shoutout on CNN.
She was fired up.
- I was.
- Did you get any love
from some of your friends?
- Yeah.
- Amazing.
Good Day, New York this morning
was very feisty. We should
have that clip shortly.
Me and Greg Kelly got in to a
young man, old man
conversation in my opinion.
- Most people when
they ask me questions
are asking me to
give them encouragement
to go for it because their parents
didn't build their self esteem.
- Ok, that's a little bit
respectfully outside your field--
- No, it's not.
- of expertise.
- I totally disagree.
- I mean look but it's an opinion.
You have one, I have one.
- Well, listen, that's fine.
That's your opinion. Now I'm
going to set you straight.
(laughter)
- And here we are, India,
and so here we are.
I think that we should
go in to it, right?
- Let's go in to that thing that we do.
- Let's do that thing we do.
- That thing that's now a book.
- That's right. Let's get into
- [Both] The show!
- Oh, your energy is not working.
This is book day.
Let's go again.
- No it's not. I can't. (laughs)
- Let's--
- Get into--
- [Both] The show!
- There we go. There we go.
India, let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Matt asks,
"What was the most difficult
"aspect about the production
of this book?"
- What was the most difficult
aspect of the production
of this book?
As a matter of fact, this was
probably the easiest book
I've ever written from
a production stand point
because so much of
the content had a framework.
One of the things I'm most proud of
is the responses on social
media and email this morning
of people that are stunned how
different it is than the actual show.
Way too much,
maybe a bad job by me,
way too many people assuming
that it was a transcription
from the show. We took every question
and answer that we did from the show
and then added 100 of
them but the ones that came
from the show, I reread,
I added sentences, context,
updated and so it wasn't super hard.
Steph Land, who I acknowledge
in the book, my ghostwriter for
the fourth business book in a row
is incredible. She knows me.
We're a book married couple.
We know how to jam with each other.
I did a lot of it during
my summer month in August
in the Hamptons. So I was
in a very good place.
It was kind of like, get a cup
of coffee in the morning,
play with the kids a little bit
and then they'd go to camp
and just get in that place,
put on the headphones
call Steph and be like,
"Alright, Steph, what's the question?
No! What you have to do is"
I would start off zen but
it went intense very quickly.
It was great. You guys were a big help.
We organized. This one
was quite smooth.
I mean honestly this
could be the blueprint
if this #AskGaryVee,
what a lot of people don't know
is that the #AskGaryVee
show ends today
and we're going to be
transitioning to DailyVee
and so with the book launch,
I'm kidding. I'm kidding.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
What's a lot of fun is if
this show keeps going
you know even though I
want to write Perfectly Parented
even though I want to write
I Wish Everyone Was an Immigrant
even though there's other
books that I'd like to write
I could see an
#AskGaryVee Book Volume 2.
I mean this is a
format that could work.
Andy, the response is real.
- [Andy] Yes.
- There we go. India.
Oh, I should answer it.
The toughest part,
I guess the toughest part was
the pressure I felt to make it
not a transcription of the
book. And that's actually
why I think the book
came out really strong.
I forced myself to go, you
know, I love to talk in tweets
and in headlines and powerful punches.
I keep my second, third and
fourth tier stuff normally
for my businesses.
#AskGaryVee, the show, made me
get into my second and
third tier stuff and I tried to force myself to
get in to some fourth
tier stuff in the book.
- [Voiceover] Keith asks,
"Can you talk a little bit about the
"outline/organization process
of the #AskGaryVee book?
"How did you decide
the best order of info?"
- Steph Land, Steph Land.
What Steph does extremely well
is she watches the last
two years of my videos
I got on the phone with her and said
"Look, these are the things
that are mattering to me."
If you remember, you might
have been on this but
Stunwin, by the way,
big shout out to Stunwin
I texted him last night
before I even texted you guys
big shout out to Stunwin
who was a big part of this book
obviously, India killed him
and he is no longer around.
We miss him, let him rest in peace.
We love him very much.
He's actually on floor 12.
Actually Staphon, when you get a chance,
I'm not even kidding,
go down and capture him
real quick just so we can edit
him in for a quick second.
Literally just roll up on him
when he's not paying attention
get it and leave.
(sad piano music)
He was a big factor.
I think we all, if you remember
there was a two hour call
I remember I was
somewhere on a client thing
when we talked about
what should the chapters be.
For some reason, patience didn't make it.
I'm devastated.
But you know, we talked about parenting
and self-awareness, we got
a lot more into that EQ thing.
We got on a two hour call,
me and the team,
we all talked about what the themes were
about 150 episodes into the show.
We got into them and they became chapters
and then I had to call
Steph and literally it was
like "Okay, Clouds and Dirt"
and then I just talked.
I just talked and then it was recorded,
she layered on grammar and away we went.
- [Voiceover] Daniel asks,
"What is the most humbling
"thing that has happened to you
"through this book's promotion?"
- I think the most humbling thing is,
this is actually very
easy for me to answer,
it's the extremities on
both sides of the equation
of the audience that consumes my content.
The people that know me the longest
the Justin Thorpe's of the world,
that are saying "Wow
this is really quality stuff."
You know, people that have listened to me
for seven years. They know my spiel.
I mean think about you and Andy,
you literally watch me at the 92nd St Y
the other day and you know what's about to
come out of my mouth before it comes out.
When you're around somebody,
right, and you're consuming.
For the people that know me the best,
to really get their
$19 worth because there's
really more stuff 'cause
I forced it to level four
and on the other direction,
the people that are in
mainstream media,
the people that are
a little more cynical by DNA nature.
The people that think I'm a loud mouth
or don't think that cursing is gentlemanly
those people reaching out,
some of the heartfelt
emails that I've got
in the last week of like
I didn't believe in you and
this has caught me off-guard
or I've never been a fan but I
had to review this for my
website and I was blown away.
Or I never really understood
that you were anything more
than a blowhard promoter.
The two parties,
really into me,
really not into me going,
I don't know, nonetheless,
that has been humbling
in the fact that I know
I've created something
really strong here because
I'm getting reactions from
both sides of the aisle.
That matters to me.
And that was a goal and that feels good
when you accomplish a goal.
- [Voiceover] Tim asks,
"What surprised you the most about
"the success of the book launch
compared to your last book?
"Thanks for all you do."
I don't know, I mean, there was so many
more of you guys than there was with just
me and Nate for Jab, Jab, Jab.
I don't know if anything surprised me.
I would say that my
team starting with you Andy
you guys really, really brought it.
You really did. I'm really
proud of the team.
And it built momentum. I think
Staphon, Andrew I could see
even halfway through like
the whole team came together.
Like you guys really worked it.
Especially since the first of
January it really was rolling.
I think the other thing that surprised me
is that I fucked up,
I didn't have that one
organized day 30 days.
There was no reason to have the fuck up of
not having that one
organized day and that's on me
not on you guys. I like how
you looked at Andy.
There's one day that we should have had
that wouldn't have
allowed all the vulnerabilities
that I can think of now.
Like there's literally like 40 more people
that I could have write a Medium reivew.
There's probably 100 more influencers.
I said this yesterday,
we said this Staphon at
the end of DailyVee yesterday
as hard as you leave it on the field
there's always the 15 other
things you can think of.
There's things that we
did better on Jab, Jab
that we didn't do on this.
That I'm just like, man.
I guess what surprised me,
it's not what surprised me,
two observations are
I'm so proud of the team,
I thought they really brought it
and I'm used to being
the strongest energy
and for the team to match
my energy or get close to it
excites me, and then two,
even with all that even when I
think I'm the best,
even with all that support,
seven, eight of you underneath me
I literally right this
minute can think of 25
more things that we left on the table.
Crazy.
That's what's important.
I think a lot of people beat themselves up
for it. I recognize it because
I want to give a good answer
on the show mainly because
I want to give you
a proxy which is like look,
you give it your at-bat
and that's what it is.
When you see an athlete retire.
A lot of big guys are retiring,
Peyton, Kobe, all this. If you
can get into that place where you
felt like look, you left a
lot on the table.
You don't think Kobe and Peyton
are thinking right now
about that one championship
that they had.
Kobe's thinking about that
Game 7 against the Celtics.
You don't think Peyton's
thinking about that Saints game.
They're thinking about it
every second of the day
because that's what winners do.
Winners think about that
but it doesn't destroy them.
It doesn't become cancer.
It's just something they love to ponder
while being equally massively content
that they left it on the field.
And that's how I feel about this book.
We did a really great job.
I'm really proud of it.
There's 25 things I wish we did.
That was deep. I like that one.
Cool. Last one, you're
excited about this one.
- [India] It's a cute-y.
- Oh, you like cuteness.
You're into cute?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- Great.
- [India] I'm not upset.
- No, I just have you
positioned as cute. You know?
Not that you're not cute,
I mean like you're not into
"Let's have pink fluffy
flowers thrown in the air."
- [India] Things can be cute
and not be fluffy, too.
- [Gary] Yes, I know that.
That's why I'm curious
to see what this is.
Let's see--
Let's see how cute this is?
- [Voiceover] Dan D asks,
"What did feel like to see
"the book in stores today?"
- I haven't seen it yet.
- [India] (laughs)
- Great question, India.
- You know that I didn't see--
- [India] What about people
tweeting you and stuff.
- That's not me seeing it.
You lost.
Question of the day:
What the hell was India
doing on that last, just kidding.
Question of the day,
yeah, yeah,
you know what, this actually
in your world too
we're going to do it together.
Question of the day:
Tag the person that I
should give this book to.
We're giving away 100 copies on me.
You're going to work with me on this.
Now these are people that 100%
don't know about what's going on here
but you see from afar
could benefit from this.
We're going to surprise
some peeps my friends.
We did this yesterday too, right?
So some people that
reply we're going to do
four or five there but we're going
big today. This is me giving
back to the Vayner Nation,
to the people that are
most important in your life
and things of that nature.
We're going to go hard at this, Andy.
I really want to surprise people.
I like that people on
Facebook Live are like,
"Whoa, whoa, whoa."
They're going to be ready
for when this goes up in a couple hours.
Staph, what do you think,
four hours from now?
- [Staphon] Yeah.
- Ok.
Facebook, YouTube. It's Facebook.
YouTube if you're watching
go to Facebook.com/Gary
please tag the person that
you think needs this book.
India, put together
a team. Garrett, Riley
so they reply in there, they go,
hey Staphon tags Terry Rice.
Riley and Garrett and you have to go
or whoever we put the team on
goes in there and says, "Hey Terry Rice."
Tag them, "If you DM me your address
we'll get the book out to you."
Let's make 100 people better.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Thank you Vayner Nation.
Go, nope, I have a different plan for it.
See ya later.
(hip hop music)